foreign
let's go out to Little Rock Arkansas to
talk to Scott Scott bail me out dude
Dr John it's a pleasure thanks for
taking my call you got it brother what's
up man
so
I am three years uh post Affair in my
marriage and two and a half years into
reconciling it
I was the one who had the affair
um I was the one who
initiated the reconciliation I I ended
it with the the other person
and told my wife that I was committed to
us and committed to doing the work to
reconcile the marriage and rebuild it
into what it was supposed to be
and uh
you know we've had our ups and downs
and at this point
two and a half years then
I am wrestling with the question of when
do you throw in the towel and just say
it's it's too far gone progress isn't
being made and we're just forever going
to be stuck
number one thanks for laying it out that
way and this isn't going to pay your
rent but
what you're experiencing is one of the
most common conversations I have with
folks post
um post affair
which is that sense of feeling of of
loyalty and guilt and I remember why I
love you and then one to two to three
years in
that sense of oh and now I remember why
I stepped out
or I remember how the the
the the
environment was was created
and I got on a track that I made some
stupid decisions
um
when you say you're ready to throw in
the towel what what's not there that you
think should be there or you would like
to be there
well I I mean what I need is I need deep
emotional connection and vulnerability
and intimacy with my wife
what does that mean those are buzzwords
that are like like Stitch on a pair of
words what does that mean
give me give me some actions
well I need her to be able to
tell me what what she is feeling I need
her to be able to tell me how she's
feeling
and communicate to me
when I am doing something that is making
her feel
less than making her feel unsafe
and I need to be able to do the same
and feel like I feel like I'm not being
punished and I need for her to come to
me confidently
and
and ultimately this this part is my
responsibility but I need to make sure
that I Foster an environment where she
doesn't feel like I'm punishing her
are you doing that
I think I am
um I'm certainly
certainly doing my best I
I mean I will readily admit
if you can name the stupid things that
the
the Wayward spouse has done post affair
to try to justify rationalize whatever I
mean I've probably done it it's just
and at the same time
I have been immediately I started going
to therapy and I've had a regular I've
had regular appointment therapist trying
to sort through
my own dysfunction
I mean no I'm not perfect uh there's a
lot of uh
I mean even just recently I caught
myself in the middle of an argument
where she did Express something to me
and I I was a few minutes in and I
thought you know what I'm actually
I've completely turned this around and
I've made this about me and I called
myself out at that point and said I
don't want to do that to you
and it's it's frustrating to me
because
I don't feel like I get anywhere with it
even when I do call myself out it's not
what the response of
you know see this is this is this is how
it is this is how it's always been
and I'm just tired I got that
but can two things be true at the same
time
yes sir can it really have been how it's
been all this time and you're both
exhausted at how you respond to things
100 percent
and that's a tricky that's a tricky
place to find yourself right
because that's I mean that's that's the
act of throwing in the towel like yes I
keep I keep falling back into Old
patterns I keep falling back into Old
situations and your body keeps telling
you you're not safe again and again and
again and dude I'm just so tired of
trying
I get that
have you told her directly what you just
told me
yes I what does she say to that
um
well maybe she
puts up regard because in her mind she's
she says you're taking an easy way out
by leaving a divorce is an option on the
table
and
it kind of just stops there
well if you put divorce on the table
yeah it
I mean I have
how is she supposed to Anchor into that
dude
no that's a good question
I mean like like so so you like you blew
this thing up knowing there's always two
sides to a story and I'm not saying
there was an environment I I'm sure
there was participation both sides I'm
not one of those guys okay but you
stepped out it happened
um
and then
I'm assuming there was some significant
fracture and you came back and said I'm
back in I'm one in
and she said cool and then somewhere
along the way in the last two and a half
years you put divorce back on the table
it's just hard to it's hard to Anchor
back into and here's the like I keep
having this sense tell me if I'm crazy
it almost feels like you're throwing the
towel in on Scott
um
I mean I I want to listen to that a
little bit more I don't think that I am
I I actually
am
pretty amazed at a lot of the personal
progress that I've made in the past few
years I is she not making any
it's hard to say I I mean this is this
is hard to say because
what I did to her is not her fault okay
she didn't ask for it and I cannot
cannot imagine
being on the receiving end of what I did
to her
um have you forgiven you man
yeah yeah I have okay
did she forgive you
she says she has
um
you don't think so
no because it it
just stands from the past even stuff
that predates my affair
just it constantly comes up and
arguments and I'll constantly I'll say
that's not cool it's like once you're
back on the hey we're on this track
that's not cool to bring up two in five
and seven and eight year old things
that's hard
I I constantly find out that she's still
will tell people randomly
about
what I did I mean I understand that
that's her story too she's entitled to
do that
um yeah
there's some sanctity sanctity things
that are private and there's some
yeah there's there's telling your story
but then there's also spreading somebody
else's shame that's that's tough
so tell me take me back take me back to
your Affair dude like what was it about
that that happened like what did that
give you
it
honestly it was
it was an ego thing it was me indulging
my ego
and
yeah but your ego needed something what
was it what'd it get it needed
connection it needed that intimacy
there was there was just a relational
hole
I needed to feel heard I needed to feel
I had influence
I needed to feel like my words mattered
and I just
I found it in all the wrong places
temporarily
and when your wife has heard that
she agree with you or does she say no
that's not true at all I was listening
to you your words didn't matter in this
house
she she
agrees to it
and then
I I usually get met with a you have to
understand my personality just I don't
lend myself to that that's that's the
response that I get yeah and I don't buy
that that's not true
it's it's a it's a that's a choice right
so I get that frustration that you're
experiencing that's tough
or there's something about the
vulnerability when you say I need this
and the person you love says I'm not I
can't do that
yeah that's a really tough spot to be in
I mean you know just a good example
um about 10 years ago I had a pretty
uh significant event happened that it
was
over professional and personal lines and
it had to do with my family it had to
deal with work it had to do I mean it
was not a personal failure on my part
um
and I remember just confiding in her
telling her kind of what happened part
of it involved me feeling like
I did not protect my family like I
should have
and I remember just kind of being met
with a blank look on that
and at that point I just knew I said you
know told me
she is not she's not going to be here
for me when I need her
and I carried that with me
was that was it real
that was very real I still deal with it
to this day
have you talked to her about that that
moment
yeah I have what's she saying she
she says that she didn't realize how
badly it was hurting me at the time
and that that that
um
what's the right word that
acknowledgment is huge but then the
actions that come after speak volumes
right
and I'm assuming there's it's like man
I'm so sorry I hurt you and the behavior
of hurting you is just continued
conscious Act of hurting me it was it
felt like
indifference almost yeah
and it's sounding more and more
um I was really captivated by
some research done by by Esther perel on
a great relationship
um minds of our time who said that most
people step out for one reason and it
can be distilled onto one word and it's
alive
I felt people say heard excited desired
wanted
but I finally felt alive again
and if you feel like you're with
somebody that is just indifferent to
struggling or I know how tough it is as
a grown man to overcome all your social
conditioning to shut your mouth and just
plot ahead just to look at somebody that
you care about and love and say
hey I really think I botched this up and
I'm so sorry and they just look at you
like I don't really care
like that's brutal man
it's brutal
yeah
I I don't think that's a pass to go do
what you did and I don't think you you
would suggest that's that that was a
pass
but not at all here's what I think I
mean you're two and a half years in
I think there's a moment when
you've heard me say this analogy but I
think y'all are here
um
where you have to turn all the lights on
turn the music off and go somewhere for
a half day and have a grown-up
conversation about are we going to keep
doing this or not
and I think in these moments
um
there has to be some Crystal Clarity on
both sides
I need you to not bring up any things
from anything from the past if I say I'm
gonna tell you this my wife has been
this kind of clear with me and it has
been a lifesaver for me
admittedly I was craving ways to connect
but she would say if I say this please
don't respond with the following two or
three things
because she knew I was trying to love
her the best I could in those two or
three things shut her down
and so she was that clear with me
or y'all go sit down and have a grown-up
conversation and say are we going to
continue this and if we're not we have
to be grown-ups about how we separate
this thing out
but I think you're at a place where
you're done wishing that things are
going to be different
you're tired of
tripping as you're practicing living in
a new way and then the whole past gets
rolled back out on you it just sounds
like a big mess
it is has she been in couples counseling
with you
we've done two intensives we did couples
counseling for a little bit
and we're not presently seeing a couple
therapists I'm I'm seeing an individual
therapist and she herself is not seeing
anybody right now okay what is your
counselor telling you to do
a counselor is
and he's not telling me to do anything
um he's he listens
um the biggest thing that he has been
teaching me it is
to avoid taking offense easily because
when I do it
takes the focus off of what somebody's
coming at me with and it puts it on
myself and so that's actually been a
huge focus of the work that I've been
trying to do sure and is he right do you
when if your wife gives you the wrong
look it sounds like you hold her to that
look for years
I think I do yeah
or if she doesn't respond in exactly the
right way there's not a you don't have a
like a a grace period it's just all or
nothing
I wouldn't say that I have a fiery
temper I don't I don't know I don't
think I don't think it's that it's not
all or nothing it is on or off
I never yell in my house but there are
moments when my wife says something the
wrong way I I'm out bye
and I'm not leaving but I have
disassociated and now she can see it on
me
right I I wear my emotions on my sleeve
okay
so your wife can can say the wrong thing
and she can see it all over you
yeah I think she can yeah
and she also has probably learned by
this point there's no coming back
I I want
direct talk I want to know when I'm
doing something right and I want to know
what I'm doing something wrong
absolutely what does she say she won't
give you that
no she won't I told her the other day
that I feel like I've been put in a dark
room and just been told to find my way
to the door that's a fair analogy I like
that and and the only way that I can
find that I'm going the wrong way is
when I stub my toe on the furniture very
fair
why won't she tell you what she needs
I think it's because she she says she
doesn't feel safe and there's
credibility to that yeah
at some point she's gonna have to be an
adult and say the safety's not going to
come back in this marriage like I'm not
gonna ever feel safe again
or give you some direction on here's the
things I'm going to need you to do so
that I feel safe
I applaud you man for coming back and I
applaud you for saying
for doing all the work you've done on
yourself I really do and I applaud you
for saying I need these things
and that's the other side to be
invulnerable is that somebody you love
can say
sorry man I can't do that or I'm not
gonna do that
or
that's just the way I am
and for everybody listen and I don't buy
that in a marriage context at all I
don't buy that Hook Line and Sinker for
anybody well that's just me I don't buy
it
it's easy
but I can tell from personal experience
there were some moments when here's how
I just and here's how I interact with
the world and if I continue to interact
with the world like this my marriage
will be over
and so I had to choose that over me
which is a whole Act of getting married
in the first place
but Brother Scott I here's the deal
you've put in a ton of work man
put in a ton of work and when you said
I'm back in and she said we're back in
y'all were back in
but it sounds like there's differing
degrees on who's working on what and how
who's working on who and when and all
that mess man and so at this point I
think it's a we need to go out and we
need to put it on the table do you want
to stay married to me
if you want to stay married to me here's
what I need and I really want to stay
married to you and please tell me what
you need to feel safe tell me what you
need to do these things and if you can't
tell me then behavior is a language then
you don't want to this thing to work
you just want me to be the bad guy
or you are are just hurt in a way that
I'm never going to be able to overcome
it and so be it
I did step out on you I did I did cheat
on you whatever you want to say I had to
cheat on you and if we can't come back
we can't come back but I need this to
both be adults and call it
but I think that's where we are I think
the intensives are cool when you have
therapists that moderate that I think
y'all are past that at this point I
think you're at a let's just go be
adults and let's just promise not to
shut down on each other let's promise to
write down things that we need let's
promise to have this really challenging
tough conversation to decide are we
going to give it 30 more days 60 more
days 90 more days
or are we going to just say hey man we
gave it we gave it our all and we could
never come back from what I did earlier
I'm sorry you're there man this is tough
it's tough tough tough
um My Hope Is
regardless of the baggage the challenges
that any couple going through the
situation can at least have enough
dignity and respect for themselves and
for the other the other person that
they're married to to be honest and to
sit straight across from each other eye
to eye and say what are we gonna do now
I'm sorry my brother let me know how
that conversation goes man because uh
I'm rooting for you guys